[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
vous m'avez fait un cadeau de noël c'est
très gentil
dont tu vas faire j'ai étudié
dans le mode d'emploi j'ai le mode
d'emploi est fait sous le capot la
sentant déjà dense as-tu gauche
ont fait voir vol olala vous renier le
pire aux la wii
[Applaudissements]
ne marche pas
je ne marche pas j'en étais sûr sa
marchandise à attendez j'ai pas dis
monde et sûrement pas n'étais pas doué
pour ce truc là je te jure un tas des
tas d'autres qualités fait pour ça t'es
pas très bien écouter vous regarde ça
marche pas voilà j'en étais sûr à
1 on entend rien n'est bon sens qu'il
musique quand même à waimes à aulas là
je reconnais mais le format bravo
joli corps jurés 95 et le bon dieu c'est
trop
très
-
[Musique]
m
je vous laisse
d'une relation oui on attend les
lellouche sunu l'eau
c'est en 2001
oui bonsoir et monétaires et alessandra
martinez qu'on claude lelouch quatrième
étage s'il vous plaît merci
relation alors madame martinez et moi
c'est claude lelouch voilà
[Applaudissements]
tout ce noir c'est bon mais c'est le
tout premier à céder famille les
premières première et sont pas malins
pour des premiers 1 il arrive qu'ils
avaient sur l'ascenseur design qui sont
déjà dans l'ascenseur pourquoi pas tu
crois qu'ils s'embrassent encore oui oui
oui au bout de combien de temps on
arrête de s'embrasser dans l'ascenseur
formation
[Musique]
bac 4 5 ans à vannes
ouais watch a au cauchemar et messi
comme ça allait bien
ça va bien physiquement ça monsieur bon
choix je veux garder
ces prêts à
jouer pas mal aussi j'ai appris à mon
italien s'est ralliée très jolie en d1
regarde a commandé la vilaine c'est à
dire une fille que magnifique maison
bois table 0 bon je sais que moi comme
je sais je sais que tu t'habilles
toulouse
dit noir et violet ça va être très très
haut voilà ça c'est
vrai chant et bien des petits partis
c'est le bonsoir bien
il t'offre un dîner codeurs jeux sont
déjà allés dîner chabadabada
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un guichet bad
alors un dîner chabadabada c'est la
belle histoire de coquilles
saint-jacques cotisé chez passé voulait
dire aux premières truffes noires salam
plaire mariage de d'autres chevreuil du
chevreuil s'est bien foutu saveurs
machin ou l de betterave est où est
alors je sais pas le dessert 4807 m de
meringue blonde
faut décoder on a un tas avoir tout
sinon
on connait pas ton oeuvre par coeur on
sait pas ce qu on s'efface bon bout
qu'est-ce que tu bois alors plus que tu
bois champagne moi je viens petites
exoplanètes et cocktails judicieux le
jeune barman nous a préparés surgelés
les jeunes fondation collations et un
jeune mâle à la monnaie j'ai mis mes
victoires il fit toi parce que tu sais
il est venu ici maintenant j'arrive plus
à ceux qui l'habitent souci maintenant
lâché j'ai essayé aussi dans qui le
petit cocktail bien sûr quanti cocaïne
et ça c'est dommage je dois t'en vois
pas un petit total 1 dans côte des
villes bien sûr d'un apiculteur et
thierry oui je pars avec toi avec nos
jours c'est en gardant les cas les
pas sont au rideau métallique est
beaucoup plus tard en compte maintenant
tu sais en france c'est compliqué je
vais dire je ne sais pas si c'est par
rapport à claude couamme et l'échec
maria metteur en scène tu lui as ruiné
sa carrière
non mais si scénique et zagat
lui imprimant bison très peur j'ai adoré
le tour c'est bourré d'armes souligné
après d'intégration et voilà et puis
j'ai fait deux autres films aussi en
italie qui vont sortir là bientôt mais
je sais pas j'ai le sentiment que les
metteurs en scène ils ont peur tu vois
en envoyant des scénarios en france
faisait la file d attente assez naze le
pépin majeur qui donne qui fonctionne à
l'émergence déjà et d'une je les rassure
parce que si tu veux claude claude a
beaucoup trop de classe déjà pour un
point pour ceux déjà il n'a pas que ça à
faire ah oui je resterai impliqué parce
que ça m'oblige en même temps si tu veux
à faire la navette en permanence pour
être après avec claude et avec les
petites filles en cuivre maintenant je
suis pas tranquille et tu sais quand la
lute appel en disant des filles est bien
de vomir toute la nuit et que toi tu es
là bas où tu vois c'est ça la fout mal
enfin bon je leur équilibre un peu dans
ton coin mais avec l'autre je suis libre
en tout temps et alors alors il m'a dit
que c'était que c'était oui absolue
d'élite ono est incroyable après quoi il
a la gueule tous les rasets que d'entrer
chez nous c'est qu'en fait c'est pas
parce qu'on pourrait se dire si un truc
typiquement italien tu vois les les
autres connaissent pas parce que
souligne etc d'abord c'est une histoire
qui a quand même malheureusement emmené
avec toute l'europe et le monde entier
par rapport à tout ce qui s'est passé
par la suite avec le fascisme et ensuite
ce qui est intéressant là c'est qu'on
raconte en fait l'histoire d'une
relation entre cette femme et son père
et donc j'ai beaucoup travaillé s'il
veut surtout l'aspect psychanalytique du
personnage et c'était fascinant parce
que parce que c'est une relation
incroyable jeu lille avait juste une
fille non lavés ils avaient aussi l'
écoute d'ailleurs j'ai fait une émission
en italie avec le fils il avait un bus
venus joli nom qui est toujours vive
après qu'est-ce qui fait son fils
aujourd'hui bailly continuer on est à
dire l accepter ancien pianiste de jazz
tomber par terre et je traînais déjà jeu
il ya eu une émission de télé d'ailleurs
où il était là et il ajouté la lfp il
est joué comment il s'appelle alessandra
sa petite fille et non à les salons
celui qui fait de la politique louis
maintenant enfin si mais l'histoire est
alors elle me disait ma tante tu vois
vrai qu'on rencontrait dans l'émision
saf étrangeté non mais c'est vrai que ça
peut être pas en france finalement
mettre la femme de java faisant
c'est vrai que y est pas qu'ils actrice
et épouse des metteurs en scène rien
emmanuelle seigner avec polanski du
melbourne cette
soirée mieux
et commettant que le temps semble très
simple on est en train de battre des
records est ce que quand vous prenez un
ascenseur vous être que tous les deux
vous embrassez vous
non bah là j'ai fait un petit réseau jeu
mais aussi la population dans ce qui
était alors une relation et moi non mais
amène dans le taxi tu es loin utiliser
mais mais mais toi parce que c'est bien
là quatre étages temps tu vas de faire
plein de choses des bisous mais bon là
disons qu'un petit puits qui par exemple
oui mais bon et moi mais moi quand je
suis dans l'ascenseur avec ma femme je
saute dessus dit combien l'économie
est-ce que tu arrêtes j'arrive pas je
souhaite quatre étages ça va
[Musique]
oui bonsoir bonsoir
français
4e étage s'il vous plaît merci
[Musique]
m
mademoiselle bonsoir
je me cachais je saute dessus non mais
je vais je vais arriver le premier je
vais lui dire
j'ai bien c'est dommage qu'elle soit pas
venu ça forestier
dont nous ne bouge pas mettez vous une
près de près de l'entrée
dis moi claude
elle vient pas sara forestier l'annoncé
des commandes et non
dommage quand est ce qu'elle sait donc
condamné à une semaine c'est dommage je
savais non moi elle m'avait dit hier
qu'elle venait pas c'est dommage
messier ne cédez commande jamais
c'est génial
ça c'est la surprise et
pleurait au téléphone étaient encore
meilleurs comédiens que je le pensais et
where regarde on a caché sans carton non
pas du tout pourquoi que tu veux
dans mon coeur est à eybens écoute à
leur écoute mon coeur moi ça me fait ça
fait plaisir tu vois
assez les vraies surprises bonduelle
m'appelle je m'escrime ingérable
shy'm a fait un cinéma incroyable c'est
bien qu'on ait réussi un terrain
d'accord très bien auquel son petit côté
arletty pensé que c'était la relative
française ouais c'est gentil mais
c'est ça c'est alexandra qui m'a
présenté sa team avait dit csq c'est
marrant parce que cette règle je me
souviens pas parce que ça mettait la
première personne qui m'a fait goûter
les lis pas la presse et les feuilles de
menthe qu'on met sur le palais
il ya des années on devait pas
s'embrasser sur la bouche un mais
parce que la société s'était ya au moins
je sais pas qu'on attend d'un simple
c'était entièrement en deux ans ce
n'était pas que c'était pas oui c'était
absolue et ça m'avait je vais tenir
cette fille a les hautes technologies
attention la reine du baiser je l'a bien
joué
a bien joué et moi je lui dis bon ben
écoute non c'est inquiète pas en plus ce
sont des jeunes demain ensemble
bah je voulais savoir si tu avais oublié
ta pas oublier en 17 heures est très
content déjà l'ensemble de maintenon non
j'ai pas du tout
jaloux déjà
super sympa non tu vois ça il le dira
jamais c'est pas vrai vous avez un truc
terrible en tongs locales tu dis
excuse moi c'est quand même terrible tu
dis les laitues par des échecs au cinéma
tu dis les femmes quand on en perd l on
peut retrouver une autre manne échec
c'est un échec
c'est terrible le dit dans son livre
devant moi qui l'inventé écoute guîtres
et ils disent l avantage avec une jolie
femme c'est quand vous en débarrasser
très vite
d'accord
c'est là qu'est ce que je fais en soit à
part des jeunes avec claude lelouch mais
ba écoute j'ai tourné j'ai fini de
tourner deux films
avec des réalisateurs très très très
très bien bab ezzouar ouais avec des
gens à qui alors auxquelles je crois moi
ouais ouais avec donc elle l'adaptation
du bouquin de l'étape il a tu joue
l'amant ouais c'est moi lcc wassim qui
fait qu'ils produisent c'est une
belgique et yannick bolloré c'est ça on
prendrait ça et j'ai tourné dans le film
de santiago amigorena
et c sont proches je suis pas si on
reconnaît non ses scénaristes temps un
mec a beaucoup de talent et c'est son
premier film c'est le mari de julie des
voix sa liste d'achats d'or je lui dis
non les rois maudits vachon
abdellatif kechiche qu'est ce qu'il fait
il fait pas notre cible le roi de la
terre mais j'ai mis des génies c'est la
vérité je sais déjà plein de trucs ouais
il tombe dans le sud de la france la a7
qui l'a pas encore terminé le tournage
dans mon cas - comme à son habitude il a
fait trois mois de répétitions et puis
[Musique]
oui bonsoir
oui je vais m'en tenir mais écoutez
lyon 4e
[Musique]
tout à fait
confirmez votre progrès fait pas si je
dois non pourquoi c'est un mot prudence
on
sait ça fait du bruit accident j'ai
comme j'ai des maux quand j'étais
habillé en blanc pour une fois alors que
d'habitude il est honteux
ça m'a fait du bien inscrit
j'entendais tout temps les gens dire ça
je trouve ça un peu ridicule les gens
qui viennent la tv qui dit ça me fait du
bien d'avoir écrit mon livre tout ça
olalala aulas
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu bois
- wattrelos plus est d'habitude donc je
continue de champagne
je vais pas le voir mais est-ce que tu
ais je tombais ne boit jamais d'alcool
un cocktail de jus de fruits mais 30
là dedans
j'y croyais pas tu croyais pas je viens
jy crois même
après tant d'années peut-être qu'à
barney mais à l'autre mettez qui sombra
ils sont embrassés dans l'ascenseur mais
normes après treize ensemble ils
continuent à s'embrasser d'un temps très
froid que l'intruse que nous on connaît
pas mais toi tu es avec ta femme depuis
des siècles si
oui y avait que là je n'embrasse pas
dans les ascenseurs
commissaire valence
je suis allé le voir sur le tournage ta
carte de police était alité dans son cas
là comment ça se passe est sympa tout ça
nul face à nice 1 1 dix habituels je te
jure je m'amuse vraiment été dans son
carnage moi je préférerais faire un
grand film à deux points ça peut arriver
qu'est ce que tous les cas quand tu là
quand tu l'a appris il était au fond du
trou en plus tapis n'ont jamais rien il
ya 20 ans j'avais rien j'ai jamais rien
eu
il a été donc j'ai essayé j'avais failli
faire tourner dans l' aventure c'est la
rentrée on était bien le rôle d'aldo
maccione et j'ai failli épouser sa femme
seule couverture de matches que j'ai
fait c'est avec sa femme il a changé la
fin de l'histoire j'ai plus mais
maintenant moi tu vois la preuve que ça
sert à rien de coucher avec les metteurs
en scène c'est que moi je lis pas je les
paye le scénario mais toi parce que tu
peux chanter des trucs mais nous coucher
avec les acteurs clés mais torrent je
t'ai toujours bien
l'idée de prendre tapis ce n'est pas une
bonne idée parce que c'est ce que tu es
dans ton moulin mais comme il avait dit
qu'il avait je sais pas combien de
francs pas rentrer les gens ont dit on
va pas aller voir le film ce sera un
bonus ça a été
on n'a pas eu la même analyse tu sais
quand un truc marche
on est toujours à essayer de comprendre
de chercher d'analyser pourquoi ça a
marché et quand ça marche pas c'est là
une chose
moi j'ai vu ça dans toutes les
expériences de ma vie quand ça doit
marcher tu peux avoir mis tous les
handicaps contre toi tu as connu ça à sa
marque voilà il ya une magie une espèce
de truc on sait pas pourquoi et quand ça
marche pas il ya évidemment cinquante
mille raisons qu'on connaît qui vont
expliquer pourquoi ça va marcher une
émission de télévision pourquoi ça
marche
ben oui on sait après coup ça a marché
nous notre film on l'a fait 650 milles
la première semaine
six cent cinquante mille la deuxième
semaine 300 et quelques milles la
troisième semaine de 120 et puis il est
mort comme ça on a fini à 1 million 300
mille en plus quand même pas mal ce
qu'ils peuvent dire les gens parlent dit
la première semaine c'était déjà loin
que c'est sur la fiche est bien parce
qu'il a plus spontanément a beaucoup qui
avait envie de le voir est ce qu'ils ont
vu ont pas 10 de ce film des choses qui
auraient entraîné je vais au théâtre
si la pièce avait pas plus mais je peux
me plantais si j'étais le même et on a
été plein tout le temps tu avais un
théâtre gfr raison c'est une une
émission je te jure tu te sentais bien
foutu s'accrocher le gras j'ai eu beau
changer le décor le sujet je les vois ça
m'a fait peur quand est arrivé
invité à la noce
ecoute-moi l'audience la première
c'était une merde parce qu'on n'avait
pas eu le temps là et tout improvisé bon
mais mais en moi la première c'est pas
mon avantage que je vais dire mais c'est
pour expliquer qu'il ya une magie situe
la remplit pas tu l'a rendu pas on est à
six millions et demi à 10h30 à l'entrée
de l'émission silo demie et l'attaqué la
courbe a fait ça
mais c'est il est très dur c'est très
dur de ne pas l'écouter et je me
rappelle quand il a commencé le premier
jour de tournage comme ça d'abord il
apprend très très vite une faculté
absolument incroyable je sais pas
comment ils créent un site ami quoi une
heure à prendre le boulot et dans la
deuxième heure il explique aux lecteurs
qu'il
ya un truc dans son bouquin j'ai trouvé
vraiment extraordinaire c'est quand ils
se retrouvent à la prison de luynes un
côté d'aix-en-provence
il le met dans une prison il a pas de
fenêtre et lui se met devant la porte
pour respirer l'air qui se couche comme
ça tu imagines ce coup devant la porte
pour respirer l'air frais qui va les
chasser toussaint tout n'est pas moi
seulement quand même mais tu prends
n'importe quel contrat il fait oui
d'accord sauf que ces mêmes faits mais
il est sain quand ils sont ils respirent
les règles sont 50 dans les
50 pas une fenêtre est en fait tous les
mecs faisait la nuit tu sais comment
dormez la nuit on dormait en prenant le
drap ans le foot on dans l'autre est
très mouillée et on se couchait avec le
drame houllier sur moi et quand ils
étaient secte été réveillés parce que tu
avais trop chaud tu retremper dans le
même club med ils font ça quand ils se
réchauffent mets là et tu meurs pas de
ça
thierry c'est ça qui est extraordinaire
c'est qu'on a une faculté de résistance
et d'adaptation
c'est pas des c'est pas des héros les
mecs qui résiste à sa simplement laurent
ricci risi
j'avais bien en ce moment oui et
rétablir mais je suis sûr plein de trucs
jeu produit le film de werner son
premier film et puis je travaille sont
trois projets
comme un fou ça m'as tu sais comme toi
comme dirait pierre darrot est la
contrainte sollicite l'imagination malin
oui bonsoir oui bonsoir cdt des
maraudeurs religion c'est quel étage ou
quatrième est
[Musique]
bien ton bouquin ouais sa part il est
sympa parce que jean la vie privée on
reste un peu sur sa faim
amoureux et sexuel majorité ok c'était
bien par les impôts de cilaos et des
cinémas c'est très intéressant
prépare à qui et pas parce
que tu as détruit un film non où est le
tout premier titre
négative
ce film m'a fait tellement mal tellement
mal si cela tu es mon frère
voilà mon père j'ai cinémathèque
tout le monde était dont il a été sifflé
pendant une heure et demie la
cinémathèque et alors ce qui est très
drôle c'est que langlois langlois avait
sélectionné le film donc je me retrouve
à 22 ans avec mon premier film qui passe
à la cinémathèque et le film a été
sifflé pendant une araignée ce que j'ai
pas su c'est que le jour où langlois la
veille il avait dormi pendant toute la
projection
mais sérieux bon joueur
la bulle super ça fait drôle de janvier
à 15 personnes mais en même temps ce
film m'a tout appris je suis doit être
ou c'était cette année un film annie
hall à bonjour
il est bien
il est super en forme d'une oreille en
forme moi je connais ton âge ouais je
peux dire que j'aimerais être comme toi
attendre
je suis toujours finalement je connais
qu'une mort c'est celle de la curiosité
quotas si tu perds ta faculté
d'émerveillement tu peux être mort à 12
ans quoi tu vois c'est pas dont il sait
qu'elle n'agit la pierre puis on peut
dire que oui bien sûr vous voyez là 71
ans et sa 72 bientôt soixante bientôt tu
vois on regarde le tu le crois pas le
mec il m'a fait écouter tom jobim et
beaucoup de respect
tarif d'où la de durite salah je peux
pas trop duré moi j'ai abandonné light
tu continues ouais j'avais jamais moi
mais moi aussi souvent qu'ils prof de
gym il avait du bide et je me suis dit
que si je
m'inquiète c'est encore à gimat du bide
c'est dans la rubrique contradictions le
mec soit disant est là pour te faire
perdre le tiers mais l'huile en bas donc
je me suis dit bon miroir j'ai pris un
coach à la maison maintenant le mec
c'est bien
parce que j'ai raconté alexandre à un
peu de hammam après tout allonge à la
piscine est jolie et j'adore
ça qui peut faire chez soi par exemple
leur entraîneur philippe djian et la
déflation les fellations s'est encore
jamais orient le problème du ritz poussé
à tarifs et des passages sais c'est que
d'abord qui va jamais ça coûte une
fortune deuxièmement le prof de gym un
du biel et troisièmement les masseuses
ce n'est pas le concept de happy ending
qui grand n'importe quel massage se
conçoit avec un happy end si l'on sait
que c'est pas pire que quiberon quand
même avec les moustaches et j'y suis
allé et quiberon j'apprends des choses
la première année j'ai à quiberon que
c'est
non mais tu vois arriver gérard
depardieu rebonds 16 tu vas première
expérience du jet c'est dans le
thé tout nu et avait pas retiré le
caleçon mais si j'avais retiré une quête
celle avisé les couilles
visez bien elle remonte le long de
l'agencé tu vas tu pas votre chien c'est
comme si elle a un flingue à la main et
une érection ce n'est pas une petite
érection que j'ai une grosse trouille g
[Musique]
c'était
oui bon choix oui bonsoir l'alternât au
quatrième étage
chez nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame monsieur bonsoir on sait
ou comme ces jeunes
table
[Musique]
et
si heureusement qu on n'est pas
déterminée son nom
[Musique]
monde ah ben oui
le chien islam
voilà ma droit
[Musique]
la ba ouai allait tuer la
forêt claire-marie 6g bernard hislaire
d'or
pierre barouh là bas pour être un truc
un président flamand a compté cela ne
m'a dit les ailes du moulin les cloches
de midi soulignant d'un sourire la
chanson des oiseaux
tu prenais du plaisir à faire des ronds
dans l'eau qu'est-ce qui a écrit ça
aujourd'hui tube est là c'est pas le
grand qui sait déjà tout le monde est
persuadé art je vais te dire un truc moi
ni connaît peu en musicologie je suis
persuadé que c'est michel legrand qui
lance le grand je vais te dire c'est un
grand musicien way le site écoute toutes
les musiques de legrand un
spécialiste pour savoir exactement d'où
elle vient si c'est un grand technicien
qui prend toutes les trames harmonique
des choses qu'il aime et qui refait une
mélodie dessus on arrive et ça c'est un
fait c'est dans le film de claude et
derrière il a fait des moulins de mon
coeur bat da da da da da douidi djadaoui
d'idées et des ronds dans l'eau ça fait
partie des chansons qui viennent tout
droit de mon enfance vendéenne quand tu
dis bicyclette c'est la chanson de que
chante mon temps oui oui c'est tout à
fait ça
la main ouais bah bicyclette
quand on partait de bon matin quand on
s'arrêtait sur les chemins à bicyclette
nous étions quel de bons copains il y
avait fait renom il y avait firmin il y
avait francis et benjamins j'ai dit
benjamin biolay tcbr nous étions tous
amoureux sont tous amoureux d'elle on se
sentait pousser des ailes a cappella
c'était beau à bicyclette à l'époque je
rencontre mon temps aux lois et à
l'époque les femmes j'ai appelé les bugs
du poker on ne faisait que jouer au
poker et attend vraiment et un jour
entre deux parties de poker on évoque la
chanson est juif chantonne la bicyclette
il avait pas fait 10 depuis dix ans et
comme un fou il me dit ok mais ce qu'il
ya d'incroyable
et c'est là où c'est remarquable parce
que aujourd'hui il ya de plus en plus de
gens qui écrivent il ya moins en moins
d'interprète les interprètes sont des
grands passeurs quel aurait été le
rayonnement de jacques prévert ou de
francis lemarque sans vivres montant que
va est le dernier couplet j'ai oublié
mais c'était pas à pas le celui là
c'était le mec qui revenait et vingt ans
plus tard en bagnole avec femme et
enfants les traces du fantôme de
paulette et ces montants qui me dit je
veux cette chanson mais ce serait
beaucoup mieux si c'était comme un petit
film qui commence le matin qui se
termine le soin donc c'est provoqué par
lui que j'ai fait ce dernier couplet que
j'adore quand le soleil à l'horizon
profil et surtout les buissons nos
silhouettes on revenait fourbus comptant
le coeur un peu vague pourtant de n'être
pas seule un instant avec paulette est
là pour toi je crois et pour nous tous
qui aimons les mots c'est incroyable
parce que quand il enregistrait j'étais
en studio il a fait une erreur mais
minime minimes et l'image se rétrécit
tout d'un coup au lieu de dire de n'être
pas seule un instant avec paulette il ya
10 de n'être pas un seul instant avec
paulette et l'image serait slimane déjà
ah ah ah ah
fait des clous à michel morvan dont j'ai
vu way ventre commence à contourner le
chat et la souris j'avais besoin à un
moment donné d'un
d'un moment de spontanéité comme ça et
on avait beaucoup de mal à la dérider
elle avait un petit peu le trac de cette
scène est donc je lui ai mis avec lou
dans un gars comme j'ai pas suivi au
début mais seulement 10 seulement corps
donc pardon ben non je veux pas
et serge reggiani le monsieur se demande
alors si vous voulez non j'avais envie
qu'elle est qu'elle est elle une
réaction je savais même pas ce que je
voulais dans le jeu ce que je voulais
c'était la déstabiliser parce que et
donc j'ai fait mettre dans le gâteau
puisqu'elle est remonté au dessert j'ai
fait mettre un clou un vrai clown ces
pratiques de l'avoir à la maison
et au bureau du tournage donc au monde
daniel commencé à manger le gâteau
évidemment elle tombe sur le coup
j'avais très peur qu'elle se blesse et
refont le coller à la roue et à la fin
c'est une scène d'anthologie parce
qu'elle est parti d'un fou rire
absolument incroyable elle a très très
vite compris que c'était un cloud qui
avait été mis par mois elle est partie
sur un fou rire et c'est vrai que ce
frère est absolument magique c'est après
on a refait la même scène sans avec le
clou si avec le clos mais avec la est
donc encore une fois ce soir là on a vu
à quel point la spontanéité c'est fort
non ces fameux parfum de verser les
nerfs quand il dit ça parce qu'après les
gens qui entendent ça au premier degré
tu sais il dix ans mais les films de
claude quand c'est génial c'est parce
que c'est improvisé parce que il ya deux
acteurs géniaux et ça ça me rend folle
parce qu'en fait c'est pas du tout comme
ça c'est je vais vraiment d'un propres
exemple c'est dans quel film sous la
tente c'est normal et bernard il a
tourné avec moi il sait très bien qu'il
ya les figures imposées il ya les
figures libres a été inventé ce mot je
suis prêt qui est rouvert au plus la
formule
derrière en train de
viser
elle était super écrite la scène il ya
des choses que ce que que que fabrice
non c'est à dire que c'est un concours
de circonstances encore une fois quand
je te disais tout à l'heure les choses
ne se passent jamais comme on les avait
imaginées voilà et donc à partir de cet
instant j'avais ce jour-là d'abord on
était très en avance et on avait deux
heures d'avancé sur le planning on était
de bonne humeur on avait fait des belles
scènes dont il y avait une ambiance
formidable et moi je joue
essentiellement sur l'humeur des
comédiens dire que tous les matins je te
fais encore une petite parenthèse quand
j'arrive ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
savoir s'ils sont de bonne ou mauvaise
humeur et je vais faire avec leur bonnet
leur mauvaise humeur je peux pas
empêcher les comédiennes arrivés avec
leurs valises et ses valises des fois
elles sont bonnes et fois son papa de ce
jour là c'était un pk il y avait une
humeur du film incroyable sur le plateau
ils ont comme en avait deux heures j'ai
fait planter une tente dans un garage
dans la maison aux tournées avec un
l'essentiel est dans la peau sommet du
mont louis et jeudi à un fabrice va là
on va faire une scène de provoc comme ça
qui fait que on va sentir que les
couples ont envie de s'échanger pan
données qui sont à 4000 domaine on va
faire un peu d'échangisme et je veux
dire en plus tu vas voir il ya eu ce ter
qui est très bloqués il faut que tu
ailles fota grèce huster est plus qu un
agressé huster et alex et plus on va
s'amuser et au moment de la répétition
je dis donc on fait le répète c'est moi
je savais que j'allais tourner de toute
façon la répétition et tout le monde et
faire ce dès que c'est la répète et si
la scène est réussi
évidemment que c'est grâce à lui qu'ils
nient et c'est peut-être grâce à uster
parce que à un moment donné donc repose
tout le monde pense que c'est une répète
et quand l'autre commence à parler de
turlutte de machin de france en
importons truc il ya huster qui se prend
un sourire d'enfer et il se dit si je
reste face à la caméra jusqu'où la scène
en l'air et ça me remet jésus
esther a vu que la caméra tourne et donc
il a eu l'intelligence de se retourner
un d'être de dos à la caméra et luchini
quand il a vu juste est replongé il a
fait toute la scène pour huster il avait
envie de l'écraser tu vois ce que
j'avais donc qu'il a joué tout sur
huster mais luchini est génial non il
est énorme mais à aucun moment il peut
imaginer que la scène sera dans le film
et personnes sur le plateau pense son
fuster qui me connaît et qui sait que
peut-être ça sera dans le finistère
sauve le coup et en même temps ça lance
lu qing encore une fois je te dis parce
qu'il sert il avait déjà travaillé avec
toi donc oui ça va plaire clos de ce
qu'il ne dit pas parce qu'il est très
très modeste ou jours mais il souffle
bien sûr derrière la caméra ce qu'il
appelle un cotisation c'est toujours une
improvisation extrêmement diriger donc
tu vois que tu as fais comme ça vient
faire d'abord lui il avait envie qu'on
se tire la bourre tous les deux
parce que lui qu'il y en avait très
envie c'était la seule raison pour
laquelle il a accepté de signer ailleurs
c'était de se dire tiens celui là qui
est un mâle alpha beta cumin
qu'un taux de notoriété qui est
totalement anormal et qui est un voyou
je vais tourner avec lui je me demande
dans quelle mesure derrière lui la pac
est capable de le faire signer en lui
disant le côté
ça l'aurait pas dérangée de le faire
et nous voilà partis dans des scènes de
confrontation et il y en a une qui a
effectivement été alors là pour le coup
une improvisation
et elle est improvisé mais lui sait
qu'elle va se passer tu nous prends pour
des voitures
et je suis censé être le mercantile le
co n'a d'ailleurs il a fait toutes les
répliques pour ça mais moi je fais le
con parce que je suis aussi malin que
lui et donc ça me dérange pas de jouer
le car alors il lui fait faire des
reprises genre alors que qu'est-ce que
c'est comment on commet devient
vainqueur va tu vois des trucs à la con
et et s'imagine en moi je vais dire à la
le marchand de télévision tout vendre
aux élus qui n'y croit ça donc lui il
croit qu'il a un marchand de télévision
et un mec sensible cultiver acteurs et
que et je vais apparaître comme le gros
con marchande télévision tu vois et ça
c'est pas tout à fait passé comme ça
parce que il m'a même sur pascal et moi
je l'amène sur la théorie de pascal et
l'autre qui fait
c'est énorme comme il est naze
complètement au niveau de la culture
générale sauf les cinq trucs qui l'a
appris par coeur la veille et lui il
savait pas ça par contre mais quand ils
voient ça et jubile et instaurer la ça
dure 25 minutes
c'est ça c'est rien que la vérité c'est
que il a monté un scénario il est
capable de d'accepter que le scénario
qu'il a monté sa tente et malade en un
centième de seconde c'est la rançon
version wii non parce que si tu veux
ouais je me régale de voir alors quand
elle alors lui sa réplique c'était là
comment on fait pour bien vendre alors
son imagination c'est quand tu veux
acheter
tu dis que c'est trop cher et quand tu
veux vendre quand tu veux vendre tu dis
que c'est vendu toi à moi un ce plan-là
mois
il écrit mais les dialogues de tapis
voilà surtout dans ce domaine tu vois
donc là dessus là où c'est formidable et
c'est confortable pour un pour un acteur
ce qu' il faut qu'ils la gagnent sa
place si tu tourner un film avec lelouch
c'est pas sans risque
parce que il dénature pas la qualité des
gens pas seulement celle d'acteur mais
celle de l'être et c'est ça qui fait
chier tous les autres dans le métier
c'est les autres dans métier ils sont
incapables incapable moi je tourne avec
des metteurs en scène depuis plus le
journée et 5 par an il ya des talentueux
des moins talentueux de traits 30e des
bons photographes débauche mais le mec
qui comme le cuisinier à qui tu
découvriras la table il en bave voilà
aujourd'hui tu vois tu es un peu de la
rouste t'as un peu de moutarde latin du
safran talus vin blanc tu as dû et le
mec qui sait pas ce qui va cuisiner
alors il a une idée parce que il sait
que ça va être un repas qui va être pour
un mariage à temps le cahier des charges
il est fixé comme le dit très justement
il y a une histoire et elle est écrite à
la rivera son aboutissement sauf si lui
à un moment du voyage il considère que
ce qui avait projeté ça colle plus que
ce qu'ils voient mais parce que c'est
comme dans la vie
comme je te le disais tout à l'heure
là ce soir on dîne ensemble on a tous
une petite idée on se fait tous un
scénar avant de venir de ce qu'on va
dire de ce qu'on va pas dire de ce qu'on
va se raconter de ce qu'on va vivre mais
c'est vrai que tous les dialogues qu'on
a depuis le début de cette soirée
moi je n'ai à aucun moment imaginé qu'on
partirait dans ces directions la marque
mais lui a vendu quoi 5 millions de
bouquins non plus 10 10 millions et 10
millions d'exemplaires les mecs n'ai
jamais invité tu vois jamais été
décrit comment on fait alors pour faire
ça il ya plein de gens qui ont la
prétention grand plaisir et dans la
création elle-même et là j'ai le bonheur
d'avoir aujourd'hui donné mon premier
tour de manivelle d'un film produit par
claude lelouch lellouche et mon rêve a
toujours été d'être réalisateur arrêts
oui et en fait même quand j'écrivais mes
romans c'était pour faire des films tout
le temps tout le temps il a tu vas faire
un long métrage j'ai commencé
aujourd'hui oui ça s'appelle nos amis
les terriens et celle attendue par tous
s'il fait pareil
c'est sur quoi ton film s'appelle nos
amis les terriens et en fait c'est un
documentaire animalier sur l'espèce
humaine tels que vous pourrez le voir
les extraterrestres très bien c'est que
ça terrestre qui arriverait il devait
filmer cette scène sur m en face et
hillairet des gens autour d'une table
train de faire du bruit avec leur bouche
de temps en temps de picorer de la
nourriture et là ils essaieraient
d'interpréter de comprendre mais c'est
l'été l'éthologie des terriens quoi
exactement les mêmes logiques avec la
même mauvaise foi que nous avons nous
dans le documentaire animalier d'un
documentaire animalier drobo il ya un
gentil et un méchant il ya le méchant
lyon qui mangent à gentil gaz elle fait
tout est truqué dans la plupart des
documentaires animaliers c'est très long
en bresse en accusant la gazelle à
l'avancé on l'a endormi j'en appelle aux
lions à l'avant ce qu'on l'a privé de
nourriture après on les lâche tous les
deux dans une zone pour être sûr que la
caméra n'était pas contre jour et pour
être sûr que le lion auprès l'eau va
arriver à choper la gazelle mais un
endroit précis où on va pouvoir mettre
leurs maîtres le ralenti parce que si on
met le ralenti ça coûte très très cher
en bobine comme le confirme en il ya un
moteur ça fait un bruit incroyable et si
le lyon n'arrive pas à choper la gazelle
fera très très chiant pellicule dont on
voit bien une mauvaise foi derrière tous
les documentaires animaliers incroyable
et j'ai essayé de montrer dans le film
il ya une partie où on filme de loin les
êtres humains pour essayer de comprendre
ce qu'ils font et une partie on prend
certains êtres humains elle est mis en
cage et on regarde pour observer comment
ils réagissent en cage alors là il ya un
autre exemple de mauvaise foi animal on
croit souvent que la mante religieuse
femelle mange le mal ça c'est une pure
erreur issue d'observation aux cages
c'est à dire que la femelle mante
religieuse que quand elle a fait l'amour
elle a très très faim si rien dans un
dernier toi
supprimons tous les soirs
mais dans la réalité la marque
religieuse mangerait palma
elle a très faim mais mange le premier
truc qui traîne comme d'ailleurs la
plupart des femelles de toutes les
espèces animales après l'amour elles ont
très faim manger progrès trucs qui
traînent speed berna je vais vous dire
je ressens un truc il a un niveau de
conscience en avance sur nous plus élevé
que nous ne nous représente pas il a un
nom mais c 'est je suis désolé ça a été
très vexé mais pas du tout parce que
c'était celui qu'avait niveau de
conscience moi je pense que lui il est
il et il est un homme vraiment du 21e
pour pour le film de claude on a filmé
des abattoirs de poulet et juste
regarder ça tous ces poulets qui sont en
train d'être égorgé à présent un moment
au moment où il y avait un couteau qui a
approché un poulet qui t'arrive à
échapper au couteau et il était comme ça
suspendu par les pattes d'un style moi
je m'en suis tiré j'ai échappé la
machinerie de destruction des hommes est
il un type qui courait qu'il rattrape et
qu'il termine et tu te dis voilà notre
espèce j'espère que c'est pas du poulet
c'est du banc d'essai du bambi
s'entraînerait je suis pratiquement jeu
pratiquement végétarien jeu pratiquement
reçues mange du poisson mais j'ai
l'impression que la manière dont nous
comportant des animaux nous définit nous
mangeons des animaux qui ont souffert il
faut arriver à manger des animaux qui ne
sont pas en mesure loin son frère
possible
encore
tué 5 et au casher ou ou à lamoura là
c'est pareil je suis pour qu'il n'ait
pas peur c'est une vision du monde est
d'accord bernard
mange-t-on bombes y dit non je crois je
suis pas y arriver je mens 3 de garde
c'est lui le soin j'essaie d'éviter mais
ce que tu manges et les chevreuils mais
je ne sens pas de
mettre le chevreuil est pas stressé du
tout j'aurais ya pas eu de stress élevé
content il est envoyé à stresser jeux
sont ravis
en fait mais l'idéal ce serait de faire
dire merci à la bête moment-là manger ce
que font les indiens c'est à dire qu'ils
tirent et ils disent merci à nourrir ma
famille là on n'a pas eu en 14 présences
et que tu arraches la carotte c'est la
carotte elle est parachutée
à ça ça m'intéresse si cher veut moins
développés mais pour que ce qui peut
permettre d'ursa raciale
c'est un apostolat ça c'est un truc
d'une assignation rien ne te dis que les
carottes sont pas pareils elle évolue et
qu'elles ont changé en deux milliards
d'années je ne suis pas quel point les
40 doivent avoir un niveau de conscience
évidemment mais je pense à niveau de
conscience est voilé mais pas pour
toujours la plus belle au niveau des
animaux j'ai connu des poireaux ou
anarchistes il dit que la carotte
ludique la carotte à un niveau de
confiance plus bas mais a sans doute un
niveau de conscience oui évidemment
vous serez pas dans le temps
d'accord finalement quand j'étais joueur
scientifique ouais j'avais fait un
reportage sur la perception des arbres
du monde et quand se blesse à côté d'un
arbre l'arbre il n'y a pas d'explication
rationnelle à sara gibson un changement
de résistivité électrique c'est à dire
continuer deux électrodes faire que les
arbres perçoivent bien sûr la souffrance
mais les américains n'en ai vécu c'est
ce que dire sur l'art quand il va
rentrer le bûcheron dans la forêt parce
qu'il y ait ce qui se dit ici il se dit
restons calmes le manche est des nôtres
bar où je t'ai connu avec anouk je vous
ai connu tous les deux magritte et quand
même mario canonge mais quand même été
mariée elle doit peut-être venir
d'ailleurs
et c'est claude qui a été témoin non
c'est toi qui es tu étais moi j'ai
présenté les a présentés après je les y
présente il est accouplé ouais j'ai
suivi devant la caméra c'est ce que je
l'aimais vraiment génial aime tous parce
qu'on a fait une fille et des fusils
avant de faire un homme et une femme
ainsi qu'un auteur assez simple une
fille des fusibles vue qui a été un des
moments privilégiés de la vie ouais je
n'oublierai jamais quinze jours trois
semaines de tournage de folie oui un
moment est le chili la colle et comment
l'état gelé connu on n'a pas la même on
n'a pas la même version j'ai connu
claude
j'ai la même nature n'a pas validé on
n'a pas les mêmes dates moi tu as connu
j'avais 15 ans j'avais un certain voilà
j'étais à l'école
18dans mise bas du lait j'ai tiré dans
le pied dans les mollets des groupes
avaient 18
et 15 ans je n'avais aucun sens et au
cerceau aujourd'hui c'est quinze ans
ferme série pretty dire la vérité ça
sortira pas dit celle qui avait propulsé
sur le film y est quoi c'est sur le film
de cannes
je t'appelle docteur il faut vous
sachiez je veux parler docteur
on revient le titre l on était dans le
désert du néguev à l'université de
beersheva
j'accompagnais claudinette est reçu par
le président de l'université par tous
les ministres et il a été fait docteur
honoris causa pour l'ensemble de son
oeuvre
parce qu'on a considéré en israël
c'était un grand humaniste il avait le
chapeau sur la tête la toge habillé en
avocat il est descendu sur la musique du
boléro et quand ça c'était il ya trois
jours on arrive d'israël pour venir
dîner chez toi
et on a fait des discours on lui a fait
des discours magnifique et on a dit que
pour son oeuvre d' humaniste pour ce
qu'il a apporté dans l'humanité et qu'il
est comme israël qui se relève toujours
et qui créent dans l'adversité et lui
ont dit il y a spielberg pour l'amérique
et lellouche pour l'europe on vous aime
on vous admire et tout le monde pleurait
donc je vous prie de boire à la santé du
nouveau docteur s'il vous plaît
n'oubliez pas comment tu as connu un
an jour
pour jour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui bonsoir
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voir
maya maya
[Musique]
oui tout seul ça se passe
quelque part dans l'espace
sur une goule
qui roule dans la
fini
tout ça ça se passe quelque part
dans l'espace sur une boule
et roule dans l'ain
[Musique]
sogetel
on se bat tera
kaki
fqu
or
[Musique]
oh
chez nous
[Musique]
où
elle en est où
[Musique]
sotchi terre
souben témoin
carlina
[Applaudissements]
et
chiu
tout ça ça se passe
quelque part dans l'espace
sur mobile
g
[Musique]
faire une samba sans tristesse c'était
une femme qui ne seraient que bell ce
sont les propres paroles de vinicius de
moraes poète et diplomate autour de
cette chanson et comme il le disait
lui-même le blanc le cul noir du goisil
j'en connais que la chanson incommode
d'autres pour qui ce n'est rien qu'une
borne de d'autres qui en profitent sans
l'aimer
moi je l'aimais j'ai parcouru le monde
en cherchant ses racines et vagabonde
aujourd'hui pour trouver les plus
profonds de ces la samba chansons
il faut chanter
on m'a dit qu'elle venait de bazillac
elle doit son rythme et sa poésie ya des
siècles de danse et de toula
mais quel que soit le sentiment qu'elle
exclue
les blanches de forme de rim blanche de
former et de rim est les [ __ ] bien née
dans son coeur
alors grande première ça m'a pris 20 ans
pour avoir une version japonaise
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ta logique de lachy die
m
le cheminot
bogota
au soleil tati non
m'hamed alger
les
dans son père n
m
pour son coeur
[Musique]
ça va
[Applaudissements]
bientôt là bon retour mademoiselle
isabelle louis salager le jeu
tiré du fonds qui l'appelle comme ça
il est sympa comme tout et là c'est un
officier m'a menti
falah change plus quoi
après
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu